こんにちははじめ雪をですね昔動画で紹介したんですけどもこちらの水を覚えてます
でしょうか
仕様ショットガンという柱があるんですけどもまぁかこの動画を見てもらったら分かる
と思いますが
いやー
[拍手]
これただのショットガンじゃなくて仕様がたまになっているショットガンなんでなんで
もとかでも打てるという結構狂気的なグッズでございますね以上でも結構出てるんです
けど
一発撃てばそこらへんのコバエとか虫とかだったらもう1型できるけど結構な威力の
ショットなんてものがあるんですよ
でここに英語に変えてるんですけどもうトゥーのショップインフォレスト会津
どういうことが分かりますか顔や目には打たないでくださいと書いてあります
つまり彼を止め以外には売っていいですとも
読み取ることができますねすわけでこれボク打ったことがあるんですけどめっちゃ痛い
んですよ
ああーおれの紹介したときにもやったんですけどそこをちょっと内出血するぐらいのい
たみんながお注射を打たれるぐらいの入ったみーのこの章そっとなんてやつがあるん
ですけどもなんだ
何度ですねこちら
開けてみましょう日本じゃ売ってないと小籔ないのは海外はバカだからもどんどんぽい
の作っちゃう
ん
ana の
何度も頭や仕様ショットがバグアソルトあーぞ2.0新型が出ました
赤ちょうどいい旅だったのにさー強化したらどうなのさ
というのも見てもらった通りアナ本当の使い方って好む人がぶっ殺すやつなんですよで
英語で書いてあるんですけどもまぁ言わせていただくと
普通の食卓塩で打てますよとバッテリーとか入れません80発連続なってますがとって
か何がどう進化したんだろうねてがバージョンアップする必要あった
もうこれで完成だったと思って
ました何かざぐるとかでも人とかむしろ狙い撃ちできるように無駄に迷彩柄になって
おりますや怖いなぁ見た目はそんなにから違うんだろうなんかそんなね驚異的に何かが
変わったわけではないんですよねここに変なアリーさんの模様が入ってるくらい
はっさくがちょっと変わってるのかあとはこんななんかきつして変わったようなところ
は
阿蘇に見えます何が変わったのねに受かったんだろう
ミニコちゃん値段だぞ一番ならして380円です振ったカーンのちょっとねっとりする
と言いますなかったんだ
なーるほど簡単に言うと仕様の消費量を抑えパワーアップしているのがポイントらしい
です
ヤバパークさせてどうするのこれで野外方は一見なのかちょうど良いためだったんです
けどこれより委託するとさあ一に打つと痛いちゃーん
よし設定が完了いたしました多分ティッシュペーパーとかだったら一瞬で完成すると
思います
できます
[音楽]
def
それでトイレットペーパーを打ってみましょう
例えるとペーパーか体感のこれ貫通さはなかなかってをいきます
というわけであのまあ正直に言いますこれから人に打ちますと前にあの自分で言ったり
を知っておく必要があるんで1回順に打ってみましょう
どうします
ああああああ
磯ああああ
うわーって泡上がってるわいやならばさーん
アップデート杖超なかったんだ
we are そうでねあの作家ん
いた目がない手記するぐらい入力ですね実際北に行ったところでいた3月と伝わらない
と思うのであの実際に人類に打ってみてどれくらい効果があるのか見てみましょう
では行こうん
ねぇクソワッハ
[音楽]
air
ふええええ
[拍手]
あーあああああ
そして ao
me
teal
ええええええ
うううううあっ
まあえーっとえっどっ
ガー